every Hollywood superhero moving forward
will be required to have at least one
lgbtq character shoved into the story
what do you mean moving forward we're
already there buddy
as occasionally happens on this show
maybe more than ever in this episode
though I am completely out of my depth
because today I will be playing the yes
or no game with my friend Eric July the
biggest comic book Maven on the right
and one of the biggest ones in the
country frankly founder of ripaverse the
founder of being libertarian we won't
hold that against him though and now a
participant in
yes or no get your copy of yes or no
over at dailywater.com shop we have sold
about a bazillion copies of this game
and it's still not as many as the number
of comic books that Eric has sold so
head on over right now daily wire.com
shop the most anticipated follow-up to
the best-selling game is finally here
the yes or no conspiracy expansion pack
is here if you haven't gotten the full
yes or no game now would be the time go
to dailywear.com shop get yours and the
all-new yes or no conspiracy expansion
pack play responsibly
Eric thank you for coming in of course
man I'm actually stoked to play this so
the first time I ever even heard about
you
my producer said you know he was this
guy you know you should have money I was
like wow that sounds so interesting but
I never man I don't know anything about
comic books I don't there's no I don't
think the audience is going to really be
there for that but whatever let's try it
out and then you were one of the fan
favorites of all time of the show so I'm
very excited here we go
I hate all comic book movies
oh Eric this is not starting off well
for you what
I hate
almost all comic book movies so I was
close
I liked Logan
and to a lesser degree I liked Dark
Knight I didn't like Dark Knight as much
as everybody liked Dark Knight I thought
it was fine I enjoyed it okay I really
liked Logan is it like because it's a
more like dark ish because it's a cowboy
movie okay Logan it was it the fact that
it was a superhero movie was kind of
tangential you know what I'm saying but
which I guess the same thing is true of
Dark Knight but the other ones like
Captain Marvel America 17 with some
chicks batting off feminism I can't I
nobody wants that nobody wants that it's
not just me everybody hates it I'm right
there with you on that that's um most of
them are terrible most of them are I'll
be the first to tell you that
um I'm not the biggest fan of a lot of
these they're not they're not really
that good but I can I can deal with most
of them let's just say that so have you
seen any of the like the Netflix ones
that were like Daredevil you like Logan
I heard Daredevil was good I think if
you like Logan and you like Dark Knight
I think I think Daredevil might be
obvious I want to see the Ripper Studio
movies that's what I want to see coming
hey man this rate it might happen sooner
than later like seriously yeah it
actually might happen sooner or later
man all right you're right
political commentary is the lowest form
of Art
foreign
would you say yes
I would say that to me
it brings out the ugly in people and I'm
not the biggest fan of it people know
that I think it's kind of in the title
but
I do think there's something to be said
for the people that are able to
Galvanize troops I think that's a
there's a that's an art net if you can
like no matter what it is but it's at
the lowest maybe I agree there's an art
but is it the lowest
that is it's it's down there it's down
it's definitely down it's down there
that's for sure down there do you know
why I say
so you're right I don't think it's okay
okay but the only reason slam poetry
that is obviously a lower form of art
than even the worst political commentary
I can see that right I'm actually I'm
actually following you I'm actually I'm
actually following you I'll drink anyway
though so you know the rules the rules
if you get it wrong you have to drink
and if you get it right you get to drink
okay okay that works for me
[Music]
it was just a coincidence that the major
opponents of the Federal Reserve died
when the Titanic sank in 1912. hmm
it was just a coincidence
[Music]
so I'll tell you what I
you're right I soft lean yes it was a
coincidence
but I tell you man I don't really like
coincidences well I know I I find them
delightful but I
often see intention behind coincidences
yes I mean
I can actually see where it is a
coincidence and I'm the libertarian here
so I'm supposed to be I know I'm so
that's where I'm supposed to be but
I don't know if the the guys that were
the actual that were advocating this
knew just how rotten it was going to be
Years Years Beyond because you think of
it even in the context of right now A
lot of people are economically
illiterate absolutely we we accept that
however you know people tend to kind of
grow out of that sometimes I mean what's
the old saying like you're you're a
conservative if you uh whatever you're
not a liberal by the time you're 17. I
have a heart and if you're not a
conservative by 30 you don't have a
brain exactly so considering that I'd
like to think that even the people that
were Advocates of it didn't know how
rotten it actually was and I mean the
people that were against it probably
didn't understand just how bad it was
going to let's say impact the economy
especially going to 1913 sucked because
you didn't just have that you had the
income taxes implemented then uh that
same year it's just a terrible well what
happened to the income tax guys we need
to figure that out and the Titanic yeah
it was 1912 I think but it was right
around that time yeah yeah that uh yeah
I I really
I like your take on it because it's Rosy
in that you're giving the benefit of the
Dow just yeah but now it's very
charitable I probably should to be fair
foreign
I said The Little Mermaid was hot
garbage
and it should only be shown to inmates
of Guantanamo Bay for interrogation
purposes
what kind of information
thank you okay so hold on but now you
gotta this is vague are we talking about
the original Little Mermaid or the new
no we have to talk about the news let's
make it apply to them okay so we're
saying that yeah
now I did not see it and I read like
half a news article about it but that's
not going to stop me from having a very
strong opinion on the subject and yes I
totally agree with that and it's
especially painful because the original
Little Mermaid which came out when I was
four or something
I I not only loved it I loved her she
was very hot
Little Mermaid all right the recent one
yeah I think everybody even the people
that were defending it they they have to
accept I mean it doesn't matter if they
think it was great or it sucked anyway
because it lost all that money or it's
gonna lose all this money so at the end
of the day I mean it's it's terrible
nonetheless I I don't even understand I
don't know if you remember what's the
actress's name Hallie Bailey or
something I think that's the lead action
tonight for the new Little Mermaid right
is Halle Bailey different than Holly
hallibur yes there's two different I get
them I don't know I haven't seen them in
a while no well she so she went on to
say that she was obviously influenced by
the original Little Mermaid she loved it
but then she flipped and then out of
nowhere she's talking about well a
little black and brown boys can see they
can finally be influenced and all that
I'm like well you still somehow got
something out of it when you were young
despite it being a fair-skinned Little
Mermaid there's nothing wrong with that
I mean to be honest I can't think of
anything whiter than a Danish fairy tale
well this so this is a big debate though
because that was that was my take and I
guess that still basically remains my
take is Han Christian Anderson you know
little mermaid is a white character and
so they're they're just race switching
to be you know provocative politically
my friend Spencer Clavin had a different
take he said that actually The Little
Mermaid should be black even though it's
written by a Danish guy okay because
where is the mermaid being spotted the
mermaid's being spotted somewhere in the
Caribbean and so you know you don't buy
it no I'm sorry I will say that
definitely African African folklore has
mermaids why didn't they just do those
if they really wanted to tell one of
those stories that's now did you hear
there's a
there's a story from Columbus's Voyage
where he sees a mermaid and he writes
about this okay and the libs today they
say well he saw a manatee he mistook a
manatee for a mermaid and I thought I
don't know man unless that guy was blind
I don't I wouldn't mistake that one up
right yeah yeah and so I don't and
they're all modern Libs so they don't
believe in any like fun mystical stuff
but I don't know I
like look I don't know maybe the guy saw
a mermaid is what I'm saying I guess it
could happen I don't know people are
talking about seeing aliens do I get the
same room yeah exactly exactly all right
although most are charlatans some
psychics are real and can actually see
and predict someone's future
foreign
in Heaven and Earth than is dreamed of
in our philosophy Horatio I think some
of these guys look they're all dealing
with the devil I mean it's all bad stuff
okay but like when the Bible says the
Bible it says don't consult astrologers
don't consult these no mediums and stuff
but I don't think the Bible says that
because it's like they're a bunch of
dumb idiots and there are charlatans who
are going to steal you money I think the
Bible says that because it's real and
sometimes these maybe a lot of them are
charlatans but maybe sometimes that you
actually can do it and that it's
demonic never heard it expressed like
that I thought for sure definitely go on
the the uh the biblical route you would
have for sure said the opposite but
putting it that way yeah I can see I
guess I can kind of see where you're
coming from so you're looking at it from
the perspective of that
they exist and because you can't
separate what is truth from what is
false
and and because it compromises your free
will so if you go to psychic and the
psychic says you know you're gonna die
on Thursday okay then if you you know if
you predict the future or you read the
stars or whatever
um you're compromising you're free will
and you're not trusting in God's
Providence you're you're trying to
assert control over the the order of
things uh okay you even see this in the
Bible in the witch of Endor when Saul
who says no more necromancy you know and
he goes to the witchy Bend Oregon he's
like hey
I need to talk to some dead people and
she goes nah King Saul said we can't do
that anymore he's like yeah don't worry
about King Soul I'll take care of him
and she goes okay whatever and then she
conjures up the ghost of Samuel but
what's real and look this is just my
interpretation of this scene but she
seems kind of surprised
that she actually conjured up this ghost
okay which makes me wonder is she mostly
a charlatan
but then when the ghost comes up she's
like oh shoot man I actually conjured a
ghost pulled this off typo I guess I
could see that I mean Bible is
interesting man I definitely read you
know read a lot more of it as an adult
and you start to pick up things there's
a little even little stuff about you
know everybody has their position on
dinosaurs and you'll hear in the Bible
is these like massive uh animals that
are around it's like well maybe I mean I
don't think we use the term dinosaur but
maybe that was what they were referring
to so yeah I can see that yeah okay all
right now I don't I'm just gonna choose
to drink on that one yeah all right
a parallel economy is the only way
forward for non-lefters today
[Music]
and uh yeah that's a that's a no-brainer
I think for me
it's there's no it's not even though for
dispute you know I think there's a lot
of pushback I think people uh
they have some sort of how do I dare
explain this
the status quo comes with its set of
familiarity as well as comfort right and
so I can understand and empathize with
people that believe that there's
something to salvage there but I think
for none left this if we're going to be
able to definitely be creative and to be
able to do it freely the parallel
economy is the only answer of course I
mean I'm trying to think what would you
and I be doing right now if we didn't
bet on the parallel economy and if the
parallel economy didn't exist
I actually don't even know I don't have
that many hard skills no I I don't think
I'd be in Hollywood like pushing a
broomstick yeah it'd be virtual I mean
you get knocked down you know um
definitely as people have become so
ideologically obsessed you know you'd be
knocked down at every turn even if you
did make any general stride you'd be
knocked down so
there's a lot of pushback on this stuff
I think there's a lot of folks that do
believe that the status quo is worth
salvaging so you know get a little uh
Nostalgia bait especially with a lot of
modern like creative stuff people are
still clinging on to that idea that
there will be room for us and like but
here's the thing is I'll use the push in
a broomstick in Hollywood example so a
lot a lot of people if you're in
Hollywood that's what you do you start
in the mail room where you start doing
these really basic jobs but it used to
be you would move up and there would be
it would you'd be building towards
something and what you're really trying
to build toward is to help create this
beautiful art or some kind of vision
that you're really believing but now you
go through all the hassle of pushing a
broom working in the mail room
for what payoff so that you can you can
push some awful message and some ugly
dumb art that the audience doesn't even
want to buy why wouldn't you just go
start your own comic book and sell a
bazillion copies that's the only way
forward and I think people need to take
that seriously as an option because you
know we've had a lot of people you know
talking about Isom too for example with
gay belt I even Cliff Richards he's a
former Marvel in DC guys you know they
tell me all the time how much fun that
they're having with working with these
sort of projects because it's more
fulfilling than it ever had had been
working for some soulless sort of Mega
corporate entity so with that being said
these guys feel like they're doing their
best work you know so I think even if
you just look at it just from the sense
of you if you're a creative person you
want to entertain people whatever it is
that you want to do you really have to
consider the parallel economy as the
really the only option because that's
the only place that you can be free to
create then you'll be rewarded too or I
mean or you'll fail but you could fail
in anything I know anybody but but at
least here
you're you're controlling the audience
yeah I agree are you you're serving the
audience here the audience kind of
controls you actually but you're you're
serving a real audience there's no
mediator in there
the iso-m
Hi Sam comic book and its main character
are attacked by the left primarily
because the main character is black and
the left is racist
that's the so primarily that's why
it's not the only reason yeah primarily
from Maryland I would say that yeah
you're correct the reason being is
because of what all that it means like
the book's existence the company's
existence alone
shatters everything that they not only
believed about me but they more
importantly believed about the audience
so it nullified them of whatever
argument the arguments that were well
people have an issue with black
characters
no that was never the issue right and
then or people don't like to see black
people be creative no that was never the
problem so you see all that stuff get
knocked down and that's why they're
they're so aggravated and angry and the
racism the legitimate racism actually
comes from the box of expectations that
they have of be it black characters or
black uh uh black creatives like you
have to think a certain way and once you
don't look I'll say this here on the
record I have not been I mean I've done
I've had my hot takes politically right
we've all we've all had those and you
get your pushback nothing has got me
pushed back and this is apolitical more
more than anything nothing has got me
more pushback than creating my own comic
book company based on this character or
the first character that we we launched
being isomp but also I've not been
called any names remotely to what I mean
I have to Google some of this stuff that
I get called from these guys who
apparently are fish they well they they
claim to be fisting or Pro black all of
this so yeah that stuff went out the
window pretty early yeah of course of
course because it really that's really
what gets the ire up it's not so much
the perspicacity of your Insight it's
not so much the Precision of your attack
and rhetoric
it's success when you're successful
that's what really gets them the most
yeah okay you're wrapping them up
oh man this is good Christopher Nolan is
overrated
I'm afraid you're gonna have to take a
little sip of your diet coke I think he
is I'm not saying he's totally uh
without Talent with the movies that you
say that you like I know I know but he's
still those movies are very good he's
very very fine director especially for
comic book movies
they talk about this guy like he walks
on water they talk about him like he's
you know Orson Welles they talk about
him like he's Coppola or something he's
not he's like fine Movie Maker but
I just think the
if if he were to make Citizen Kane if
you put him to make the Godfather or on
the waterfront or something like that I
wouldn't be he wouldn't be up to the
task okay for me did I get that right
oh
wow okay huh okay the reason being the
reason being is because people look at
what he like if we talk about the movies
that you were just referencing as that
being the definitive version of those
characters and they're not
um they're not they're not and how much
artistic license far too much I mean top
to bottom really it's this replies
really to everybody that's been in
either of those movies
um that doesn't mean that if you look at
it isolated that they aren't good yeah
so I don't want anybody to thinking that
I'm saying they suck no but that's where
to me they're overrated because now even
to this day people look at and they look
at like what's the one of the greatest
comic book movies or trilogies or
whatever what do they point to The Dark
Knight okay right there and I would say
maybe if you look at an isolation but if
you're talking about adaptations no no
I'm sorry I can't I can't I can't go
that far right because I think even if
like I just use the like Joker of course
you know and you're the man one and
you're just like man that that was an
interesting movie I enjoyed it there
were very memorable scenes especially at
the end
but that's not the joke I didn't know it
isn't that's just like a crazy guy you
know it's just like interesting to watch
a movie about a crazy guy yeah but yeah
that's what it is yeah okay
in movies and TV men are held to a more
unrealistic body standard than women you
know it's like us men man we just don't
get enough
uh
[Music]
foreign
I'd love to complain as much as I can
okay but now you can you can be a kind
of dad bod guy and still get away with
so that was a specialty from the 50s
when even the most fit guys were just
like kind of fat yeah but it's even true
now a guy can kind of get away with it
I'm thinking of
obviously older actors can really get
away with it but even younger guys I
mean Leo's going through dad bodfaces
right and whereas for women they they
either need to be cartoonishly ugly or
they need to be very hot I'll say this
I think men look at definitely like in a
superhero realm they look at they look
at it different than what women do right
so when for whatever reason women see a
very attractive even in a comic book
right it's like oh it's unrealistic
where her organs they'll say if if she
is fit and for us it was just different
we would see He-Man and he's rejected to
the gills and a lot of dudes looked at
it like I want to get I want to get
buffed up you know what I mean I want
that's something to strive for and I
think still to this day when you look at
some of these animated Goku has muscles
where a guy I don't know if he can
actually really get there but it's still
like oh I can be that person that's how
they look at it so I think it's uh it's
just a difference in approach we just
don't have an issue most men don't have
an issue right with seeing it versus
women when they see a lot of characters
or female uh characters it's just nobody
can look like I could look at a modern
Batman and who's like built up like the
craziest muscle man ever and just
thinking like okay well man that's
Batman that's bad but but do you think
you're right in comic book movies
the men tend to be pretty jacked except
for Spider-Man
yeah kind of like a lean like BB kind of
guy yeah yeah okay
I'll choose to drink for that okay
you're up
in general the left wind's more
Libertarians over than the right does
um
you're gonna say no
but I am going to say yes and if you had
asked me this question
seven years ago
I would have said no okay the right gets
more libertarian because Libertarians
cut the right Libertarians and leftover
terms right
I always said the right gets more
Libertarians because that was the era of
the real hardcore libertarian types of
Ron Paul people of course and the kind
of laubertarian Internet fashionable I
just want to be liked libertarian types
they still went along with Mitt Romney
or Paul Ryan or whatever right
Trump I think broke that and I think you
had a lot of libertarian or libertarian
adjacent Outlets who just hated this guy
so much and in part because he was more
statist and more authoritarian than the
libertarian types present themselves as
at least that
they tended to go a little bit more
either third party Evan McMullen Egg
McMuffin type guy in 2016 or even some
of them now are openly Democrat I'll say
that I think that you're at least
correct that in 2016 there were a lot of
people that claimed to be Libertarians
that prove that they weren't actually
that it was more of and I think a lot of
them fit the bill of the latter position
it is that you you mentioned where you
have Libertarians or people claiming to
be that that more so use it as on some
Edge Lord stuff like hey I just don't
want to be lumped in with these guys or
that guy so I'm gonna I'm above it all
yeah I'm cool yeah and and I think that
the only reason why I would say that I
would I would kind of detach myself from
that idea is because
I look at while that was true we saw a
shift like in the libertarian party as
an example where the mises caucus guys
took the entire party over and they were
like you left this all up out of here
and they are still screeching and
screaming about that right now like oh
my God look at a little fascists now run
the libertarian party because you have
actual people that actually believe in
libertarianism running it and
unfortunately and I actually thank Trump
in that regard because he showed like
these people are more libertine than
anything
exactly right than anything they're not
they don't actually value Liberty by any
means yeah no that's such a good point
and this is the other thing I've noticed
it's why I can never totally discard the
Libertarians is the the real hardcore
types not the law births not The
Libertines but the real hardcore
Libertarians I disagree with them on
their premises
but I often agree with them on on many
of their conclusions it's sort of like
the Mormons to me you know the Mormons I
don't I don't buy the premises of the
religion
And yet when I look at the outcomes of
Mormon societies
I agree with a lot of what they're doing
right and I think there's uh yeah the
purging of the law births the purging of
the squishes that's that can be very
helpful oh yeah most definitely I'll
drink to that anyway yeah yeah
the main reason the left is so focused
on destroying superheroes and rewriting
their Origins is because many of the
traditional Heroes reflect Christian
values for example with red power comes
great responsibility Uncle Ben and uh
from everyone who has been given much
much will be demanded Saint Luke chapter
12 verse 48.
uh
foreign
I can agree with it too it was certainly
a lot more traditional back back in the
game that's it yeah that that's more of
the term that I would certainly use with
a lot of these characters I mean even
with uh Superman you know truth justice
in the American way
um they they kind of went back on it now
they're trying to bring it but I think
they realized how much of a terrible
idea it was to try to drop some of that
some of that rhetoric I mean what did
they say in the in the movie this was
like 15 years ago they said it now it's
going to be truth justice and all that
other stuff
they took out the American
most definitely now they probably take
out truth and Justice oh no I would say
I mean at this rate definitely uh the
direction that they're going I don't
know if you know that they I remember we
talked about this on on when we
discussed this last year how now
Superman's son is uh gay
yeah that's a thing it's uh out of
nowhere he's uh and now just they didn't
they didn't stop telling you about it
either they made sure that everybody
knew just uh how gay so who's the lowest
Lane of the gay Super Junior
uh how do we he has uh neon colored hair
like seriously I'm not even Leroy Lane
is it Lewis Lane
is some guy that has a neon colored hair
so you know it's it's Dennis Rodman yeah
I guess I even did I think Dennis Rodman
will be more manly than uh than that uh
the constant news of aliens is a
distraction and not Proof of Life from a
galaxy far away
Eric you're going to be hammered under
what yeah bro it's a complete
distraction and it's a distraction
either by the government because you
notice whenever there's a hot political
story like they're indicting the leader
of the opposition all of a sudden these
UFOs start popping up everywhere so but
but I don't even buy that totally I mean
the government's always trying to
distract us with all sorts of nonsense
but
uh it's a distraction by demons who are
here to lure us away when you see
like weird flickerings that defy all the
laws of gravity that don't really make
any sense based on everything we know
about physics and and even light even
the speed of light uh and you know
they're they're making these 90 degree
turns in the sea at like a thousand
knots or whatever I don't know whatever
the g-forces that totally exceed
expectation
um
it's because it's demons man so you
think
be it from the UFOs
or the unidentified things yeah
paranormal you think it's demons well
yeah I just think the only aliens more
demonic yeah it's demonic in the sense
that it's not corporeal so it's okay the
I think that the only rational soul in
the created Universe with a body is us I
think we're the Pinnacle of creation
creation is for us and that's why we
don't you know like a dog doesn't have a
rational Soul that's why we don't put
them on trial for biting people and I
don't think there's some superhuman
Martian type thing out there somewhere
either I think it's really really us uh
but there were intelligences that are
more intelligent than us just as there
are things that are purely physical and
not intelligent Like a Rock there are
things that are purely intellect and not
body like angels and demons and
spiritual things and we all I know this
sounds kind of kooky in the modern era
but you know we all acknowledge
spiritual reality because we say there's
morality we say that there is you know
metaphysics like Hope and Dreams and
loves and all that so if you if you
believe that God exists at all right
what you're saying is that God the
Father
is
metaphysical he doesn't have a body
and so we're granting that there is at
least one intelligence that is not
corporeal
and then if you believe that then you
you might believe whether through your
natural reason or more likely through
Revelation that there are other
intelligences that are not corporeal and
I think that's what people are seeing in
the sky man I can I can go either way on
that or I can say a little bit of both I
do for sure believe that there are
demons I I think that there are things
that exist that are here that have been
here
and are
it's it's it's far more difficult to
explain
I have however I I still think that
there's an idea of something beyond what
we know to be our planet
that has something that has that has
any kind of life or intelligent life I
think intelligent life maybe not
intelligent enough because I look at it
like you know earth like we have these
people that we like to think are
intelligent right and we haven't quite
figured out how to even navigate outside
of
yeah to be fair we haven't figured that
out so I'd imagine that there may be
intelligent life that also has not been
able to crack the code on that so
they're contained to their geographical
area now as far as them coming here
which they would have to be Uber smart
right to be able to figure out how to
leave where they're at to get here
that's where I think the debate more so
needs to be had and I don't know if
we've seen anything that's that smart
because you know often I was talking
about this with a buddy not too long ago
you think about these guys they see
certain thing and it's like hey this is
alien right and he's hiding behind some
car or something I'm like I don't know
if they were that intelligent to figure
out how to get get here who can they you
know would they be able to why why on
Earth that's that's how they would react
I don't know about that yeah that you
just stayed like are in your backyard
yeah you're scampering away yeah I don't
really buy that yeah that's my thing
okay uh who's up I think it's you that's
your right I've had I've had three sips
of my Martin I didn't have lunch today
though that's why
RFK
Junior I assume has a better chance of
being in the winning ticket in 2024
election than Joe Biden
all right that winning part is yeah is
the key not the nominee on the winning
on the winning ticket
not a chance no it's not I'm not saying
it's not a chance that you know some
crazy world Trump picks Bobby Kennedy
they run and they win somehow I'm not
saying that can't happen
today if you said odds are who wins the
presidency 2024. Joe Biden I mean they
kind of scooted him in there right um
and he's we can think of it he's as
crazy and old as as all get out but if
you don't think they would pull the
stock if they have they already put all
the stops they could last time with this
they especially would so I just I just
can't I can't see it I like to think
that maybe but that's me being too too
optimistic that's right if I'm gonna be
rational about this situation yeah
considering all evidence there's no way
that they would even allow that to
happen I think they found the other day
they found 300 mail-in ballots from 2020
in a locker in Michigan and I know all
the the unit party says we're not
allowed to ever raise any you can't I'm
not raising any questions it was the
2020 election was the most secure
election ever in all the history of
democracy but I think man there's
probably a lot of lockers in Michigan
you know probably a few and it'll be a
lot more yeah that's for sure all right
you're up
Plato was clearly on shrooms when he
said Atlantis was a real place
well hold on I don't want to give I've
got to give it this is I'm not very
subtle Okay so
Play-Doh was on shrooms give me a break
you know there were a lot of weird
druggy Cults back in ancient Greece but
Plato was not among them okay and
Atlantis maybe it was real what's your
tick
what did they say as far as the C they
say what is it five percent of it has
been actually discovered right yeah
and we know that there's all sorts of
things that I mean Through The Years you
know new thing that got discovered in
the sea like this creature might have
looked like this and it's like we
clearly haven't seen everything yeah and
we were just talking about mermaids
earlier on so yeah maybe that's where
they're at we haven't seen I mean to you
not that we haven't seen everything we
haven't seen anything we have not really
explored the ocean I was just talking to
a friend of mine there was that tragedy
obviously in the ocean a little while
ago and
back when it was unclear if the people
in that submersible would still be alive
or not and I said I asked a friend who
was a special forces and is there any
way to locate them he goes
fancy ocean no like you can't it's the
ocean you can't find stuff in the ocean
basically you know but like wow you're
you're in the Navy you're supposed to
know but it's just
we talk about exploring outer space but
you know when would we even begin to
start
seriously making a dent into exploring
the ocean
that's true exactly even a better point
I mean you look at
it might maybe that's the you deal with
finding what's in the ocean before you
even Explore that idea because it has a
lot I want to say similarities but as
far as the pressure and all that all the
stuff that you deal with in if you went
to space uh as well but yeah it's here
you know and we haven't figured out how
to how to actually navigate it because
of that I I believe definitely deep down
in there some probably crazy animals out
there man yeah insane ones and some
super
hot mermaids
yeah
every Hollywood superhero moving forward
will be required to have at least one
lgbtq character shoved into the story uh
yeah what do you mean moving forward
we're already there buddy we're already
oh I have that I mean they're not even
able to get nominated for certain Awards
unless they check these boxes right Nate
so Hollywood did themselves in this is
why I've said it might get worse before
it gets better yeah because they've made
it abundantly clear and they they love
that stuff right it's all about the
peers they really don't care about what
customers think at all it's like they
want to get the admiration from the
piers yeah so and the investment from
the web of course yeah exactly so it
would be any of that ESG stuff whatever
that is they have to check the box so
they feel like they have to check the
box so for sure you're going to get even
though it's an over representation I
don't know if you if you saw that glad
they had did some like end of year like
um they went through all the TV shows
and they were looking at it's really
detailed and in comparison to the
population it's they're actually vastly
it's not even close over over
represented wait honey you're not you're
telling me that not 97 of human beings
are like transgender or something it's
not even close so when they published
that I was like they're kind of doing
themselves in uh there because they
that's what they've LED with right they
need to be represented like this uh the
world outside and this is how it looks
nowadays this is why old stuff has to be
changed because this is how it looks and
you see those percentages and it's like
20 here of uh of like 50 here and I'm
like wow this is uh this is a high uh
you guys are vastly over represented
yeah so you didn't realize that
everybody was a lesbian who knew who
would have thought
out here
it's racist to cast Black actors as
traditionally White characters
it is racist it's racist
to cast Black actors as traditionally
White characters
well I'll answer for you I'm actually
kind of torn under myself okay
it's racist against
I'm gonna say you would say it's not
racist it's just like stupid
okay I would say
I would say both I'm gonna tell you what
I'm gonna make my case here so I call
this tokenism that's the term yeah I see
you know that's what I call it so when I
see race swaps you can even apply gender
sexuality all that stuff I I call that
tokenism so for me I do think it is a
slap in the face and I do think it is
the reason why I was College slightly
racist and I don't use that term loosely
yeah it's because
they often like let's speak about civil
here superhero excuse me they generally
have a big pool Marvel DC they have an
encyclopedia that they put out all the
time yeah where they have a I mean an
incredible amount of let's say non-white
characters
they get left on the shelf and their
version of representation or trying to
do something that is quote unquote black
is turning something that everybody
recognize everybody yeah yeah recognizes
as white
yeah to just race swapping it yeah and
then they just say hey here's a pallet
swap it's a new character like no it's
not it's just that character in
blackface that's all yeah yeah that's
true no you're right and it's racist in
the sense that it is
the decision is made almost entirely on
the basis of race yes and it's yeah
that's a primary determining that's true
the counter example to this is Denzel in
Macbeth I think I I think that I love
Denzel Washington I think he's one of
the greatest living actors and
Macbeth is a Scottish character yes so
you know you'd say okay it should be a
Scottish Park but Shakespeare I think
has transcended a limit for that that
virtually no other writer gets to
transcend where his plays are taken as
so representative of the universal human
condition that
you can do it you can get away with it
it does it doesn't bother me on the
screen whereas like uh black James Bond
I would say well I don't know James
Bond's not black I know he's like uh
much as I love the James Bond movies
they have not transcended the limit
where I think they're talking about a
universal Human Condition okay and so so
I think and and also uh Denzel's
performance was just so good do you
think that's like the time that has
passed that makes you to you do you
think that if that's what makes it
acceptable no I think it's that I mean
we call Macbeth the Scottish play but
it's not it's not just about Scotland
it's not just about Scottish people it's
about human beings and power and
ambition and whereas James Bond is
really about like a British guy you know
yeah and
so with that would be one exception now
there was a big debate on this back in I
think it was the 90s between uh this guy
brewstein who's the head of the El
repertoire theater and then uh took over
a theater in Boston American the
American Repertory Theater I think and
uh August Wilson who was one of the big
black playwrights who did fences which
is another Denzel movie actually and did
my rainey's black bottom and all these
all these plays they were that are
pretty good they're not they're not
Shakespeare but they're pretty good yeah
and brustine was a white liberal and he
said you need to be able to race swap
you need to be able to have colorblind
casting and August Wilson who's I think
he was mixed race but he identified as
black he said no you need white parts
for white people black parts for black
people
and
at the time brustine's view was the
liberal view but now August Wilson's
view is the level of view and I don't
know it just keeps switching and
anything you do you're damned if you're
doing damned if you don't okay but I
agree I guess okay I'm going to give you
the point that you got me right okay
because it is
when they do it they're doing it because
they're saying like Hey we're going to
give this little token to a black guy
and we're gonna Stick it to the white
guy yeah that's true that's that's true
most definitely
drag queen Story Hour is protected under
the First Amendment
no it's not my man here we go
the reason why I'll say this is oh my
God definitely because it involves
children obviously that's the big the
big issue with it a core issue with it
but you look at even what historically
actually drag has a lot of similarities
historically to blackface yeah yeah if
it's actually came about around the same
roughly the same time and really for the
same reasons to be completely fair you
have black actors uh That Couldn't act
in these plays obviously and they
thought to make you know these sort of
hyper uh weird versions of them and they
used to do the same thing with uh uh
women and for me it became this side for
them you know this Uber sexual thing
yeah yeah and I think if for people that
value Liberty and I'm saying this
obviously as a Libertarian we recognize
that you know children and protecting
their sanctity is something that should
be of the utmost importance right and to
me drag queen Story Hour you take this
sexualized sort of of I don't know
subculture whatever you want to call it
yeah and you're like a burlesque show
yeah for parading around and that and
then speaking to children like that
would I would imagine though
unfortunately not not enough people
would be against that and that doesn't
fall under some umbrella of being uh of
it being Liberty or being based on
Liberty if we if we accept that children
can't consider we it we uh accept the
idea that their their innocence should
be preserved yeah then that is something
that is rotten and abort right so that
that's my that's the thing about the
really hardcore libertarian types today
who I who I would identify as on the
right
they're not these relativist squishy
jokes who say you know well actually you
know James Madison secretly wanted a
bunch of drag queens yeah jiggle for
kids like are you kidding he's rolling
in his grave thinking about that the
ones today who are really hardcore are
the ones who have a not a relativistic
framework very
hardcore objective framework of morality
and they say no you know they're the
ones who are pro-life yeah it's the
squish Libertarians who say well
actually you know the state's going to
saw it or whatever you know and it's
like no you're saying that actually if
if we have any rights at all we've got
the right to life yeah yeah no that's
great that's good you're making me a
Libertarian
My Success early you're making me at
least very amenable temperature
oh
metal is the only genre
worse than rap
you'll say no of course I mean obviously
this is this is uh this is rigged yeah
this is rigged by The Producers
um I'm a big metal guy huge metal guy
massive
um performant and
though I will say that if I am to put
them both like on a just straight
artistic level
I have to put metal above a wrap yeah
and I say this is a guy that has
performed in both both genres though
yeah as of late primarily metal just
because the instrumentation and all that
stuff it has a level of creativity that
comes with rap but
you can't really get away with being a
terrible
metal artist but you could certainly get
away with being a terrible rapper so
yeah that way I mean
no man listen I mean my name is Wonder
Mike and I've come to say hello to the
black the white the red and the brown
the purple and yellow
so I'm very well aware of the
intricacies of rapping I think you're
right too on the instrumentation because
you know metal is too percussive and to
um
flat in its
harmonics I think but the Melodies can
be really wild right because you know
not the vocal Melodies but the guitar is
just like flying everywhere you know
everything like inve Malmsteen or
something like insane you know virtuosic
playing whereas for for rap you don't
usually get Melody
the you do you get you get too much
percussion in metal but you also get you
get too much percussion of rap too so I
think that's about even the one the one
I'll probably get canceled for saying
this the one exception to rap though is
like Kanye who in at this time of
hardcore gangster rap comes in and just
reintroduces this really light melodic
kind of musically interesting creative
absolutely yeah and and there but that's
the problem and why if we're going to
talk about it as a genre uh you know
yeah you have those you Kanye's the
Lauren heels and the the the people that
are producing the rap rap that have been
able to blend genres as well as be able
to obviously show that they have a
creative bone in their body and even
like from the rap stuff you know the Nas
is where they've been actual word Smith
right yeah not just rhyming the end of
the word but like being actual Wordsmith
but again the problem is is that as a
genre that's that's not the main thing
like that's not what's going to hit the
Billboard charts it's not what what's
being uh created whereas again with
metal music there's no room for that
there's no uh I don't know who the maybe
a hot rapper is but there's no like
metal equivalent
yeah okay
here we go then you get the last score
it's okay to drink Bud Light
you know remember with Seinfeld and I
said like no there's anything wrong with
that
if you're picking up that Bud Light man
at this point yeah you're gonna get
judged and uh rightfully so with um like
I'm not saying that I'm gonna like
send the police to your home to arrest
you if you but it's like it's not it's
something or a little wrong yeah I mean
it it this thing became so massive man
that yeah even like normies know about
what's going on with it like even people
that just don't they don't keep up with
that's the marker is when the normies
figure out not these people who are
watching politics all day yeah yeah the
normies normies Now understand it and I
think yeah I mean if their stock is
anything or their brand in itself is
anything the show for it people are
responding the way that they are and but
yeah you I mean we make jokes about it
now I don't think that's ever going to
go away you do something mildly fruity
we're gonna say oh that guy drinks Bud
Light that's just what it is I knew I
was at this
wedding for my cousin and some you know
the cousins are pretty close and we got
a bunch of them and this one
cousin comes over he's like hey hey
Michael um you need another drink I was
like yeah I could have a drink it's like
cool I got your beer I figured you'd
really like it you know it's a Bud Light
and I thought man if this is a I've had
liberal friends make this joke I've had
cancer I've had not that politically
engaged I thought
oh that's bad you don't come back from
becoming a meme oh you don't you know
there's no turning around from that okay
all right last last one
see what we got
women should never fight in action
movies
it ruins the movie about nine I think
this is the key 97 of the time so if
maybe you disagree on the percentage but
let's say 97 of the time
so the first part women should never
fight in action movies
[Music]
I don't like to see women being hurt
okay so I lean a little bit yes but as a
hard rule for filmmaking
the problem with women fighting in the
movies is not the fighting it's that
they beat up the guy okay which is
absurd and so women I would I would
allow in very you know Tastefully shot
you know where it's not too graphic or
anything I would allow the studios to
allow women to find the movies okay but
they have to lose like you can't have
some little girl beating up the Hulk you
know and and that's why I would say
you know hmm okay this is what I'll say
okay
I think if it's done and even definitely
especially would be like Kill Bill or
something you know yeah fighting like
even another woman or something like
that yes yeah yeah that's true I think
that that could be that could be huge
um or if they have powers obviously you
know what I mean like that makes it make
a little more sense but I'm with you on
for a gun I can that's the that's that
that's probably even better that that
that's the great equalizer they all say
but yeah if you get some like scr even
if they do have powers but if it's like
some scrawny and generally they kind of
do that not built probably it's not
believable right yeah and it's like the
first thing is going to go on your mind
it's like all right this chick just went
in Black Widow kind of it happens
sometimes right where it's like she just
went in and destroyed like all of these
built dudes that are also like
probably as uh
in in levels of uh expertise probably up
there with her maybe that doesn't happen
right it doesn't happen to that degree
so in the action movie I I I yeah
I remember in one of the new star warses
one of the Disney Star Wars is I guess
it's the first one maybe where the
little girl is fighting the big new
Darth Vader guy and they're fighting
with lightsabers I thought like that's
not that's not believable that's not in
any way like do you know what muscle is
do you know do you know what swords are
like to fight with that's not it's just
so I'm right there with you on that like
but I do believe that it can be
believable I think it can be believable
and we need to explain it I mean you
can't it can't just be like okay I'm a
chick but I've got girl power well yeah
see in that team since why I think so
many people are leaning towards this
moronic idea that
well people have a problem with women
being in action films and I think that's
less of the issue I think more is the
setting that they're being put in and
people are like this is corny and right
I can kind of I can be with be with them
on that yeah I'm happy to have women in
movies I really enjoy it when women are
in movies but they gotta play women they
can't be playing men no Eric I I truly
have no idea who won or lost that game
where can people get that comic book
ripaverse.com you can go to the campaign
page there you can pre-order get all
your perks we got bundles people able to
save money we got several covers as well
of that that's the main cover right
there but there's several other covers
that you can get I'm as well and um just
we appreciate it we appreciate it big
time this is something that's been
unprecedented it wasn't supposed to
happen when it happened the first time
and it it here we go again it shows that
it wasn't just like it wasn't a fluke no
not by any means so I'm very
appreciative my team's very appreciative
and look I'm just thankful to be in a
position where we're able to employ
people in an industry that people
thought were dying you know that's a
challenge not not only have you softened
me on libertarianism
you've softened me on comic books I is
very impressive Eric thank you for
coming on hello brother see you next
time and we'll see you next time on yes
or no
foreign
[Music]